hi I'm Tony today I'm going to talk
about experimental support for RDF and
the query language Sparkle and how it
all relates to entities hi I'm Tony I
have you been in my talk last year about
entities who of you knows about entities
who has built an entity store okay do
you know any graph databases ok one two
good so this talk is about a lot of
topics one of them in the center is RDF
a format for graph like data and sparkle
a language for querying graph like data
and also about entities how you can
query entities using sparkle and how you
can Beck entities by graph data so but
to get to that in the last slide we need
a lot of preliminaries so I just start
this RDF the resource description
framework so what is the resource every
every object or every formula or every
concept is a resource and it yes like
that yeah
Oh louder okay so every resource needs
an identifier and resource description
framework defines how these identifiers
look like and they are IR eyes which are
something like web addresses are they a
superset of them now so here's an
identifier for the concept adrenaline
and here's another identifier for
property the label property and it's
important that we have these long
identifiers you know I'll explain later
why
and then there literals because you
might create an identifier for the
number 15
but it's so common that you can just
write out the number and then there are
strings language text strings and more
complex datatype literals that means
what is the datatype literal and out AF
you know so let's see if you have just a
string here you might not know what it
means but this iri to a datatype defines
what this string means how you have to
interpret it yeah so we can in principle
store arbitrary data in rdf you can just
define your own new datatype standard i
said somewhere published what it means
and then there are these blank notes
you'll see them later so from these
three sources you can form statements
like triples yeah Albert Einstein was
born in Ulm it's a short English
sentence and it has an encoding like
that a subject predicate object this is
an identifier forever Einstein it's not
so human readable but that's what we
have this label property for ya here is
some property that says born in and this
is an identifier for the German town or
now and then you collect these graphs
together into you collect the triples
together into graphs you know so this is
a triple graph and various graphs taking
together form an RDF data set and we
have a function called graphs door by
the way it is all experimental and you
can't use it yet so very so a graph
store has a default graph and a few
named graphs yeah for instance this
graph contains the population of certain
countries like this is maybe the latest
population but you have a different data
set that refers maybe to a year 1986
and you have a different population for
the same entity so that is one way to
model dated data so
let's see how a typical RDF graph looks
like so first you choose some
vocabularies it's always good to reuse
vocabularies that other people have
defined because then when they import
your data it's already an ambiguous what
your data means so here are some common
vocabularies like RDF and rdf schema and
i also use the time ontology because
that's important in cooking and then i
define some symbols here you know so if
I say RDF of type I get this long
identifier now so I introduced some
functions to work with them so and then
I build a graph yeah like here my
favorite dish rice with mushrooms it's
of type recipe now I didn't want to mean
you identify so I used this example
namespace and it has a label so a
machine would know that this is the
thing to display to a user when they
present you the recipe you know and then
the recipe also has some steps like
heating the oil and cooking the rice and
these steps have some temporal relations
like I'm using the word after from the
time ontology and that means frying the
mushrooms happens after heating the oil
and you need to prepare all of the
things before you can mix them you know
and then from the time ontology also I
can specify how long certain steps take
and then you can export that in various
formats so the various formats for
storing RDF data and one of them very
nice one is turtle and it writes out the
prefixes that I used and then in a very
compact way groups statements by subject
and eventually even by object so it's a
very compact representation of that
graph and to see that it's really useful
that you can do something that you just
imported again yeah someone else could
do that too and then you verify that
these graphs that the one you started
with and the one you just imported are
isomorphic yeah and that's what you
wanted to do so home
yeah build a temporal reasoner that
figures out whether all the constraints
the temporal constraints are satisfied
in a given recipe now sparkle Sparkle is
a query for querying this kind of RDF
data and it has various forms like a
sparkle select query now so you start
with some kind of simple triple graph
that contains like data about fruit like
banana is yellow and the strawberry has
a shape round and then you write a query
that you apply to this fruit graph and
the contents of this query operator are
a graph pattern and this graph pattern
consists of one triple pattern so in
this case every symbol is considered a
variable it's similar to integrate or
table where symbols are the other local
variables but we can talk about that
whether that is right to do so and then
here's another pattern we want for every
fruit the color and optionally the shape
so here you see the results in this one
case you get the color and the other you
don't get the shape but you still get a
solution if I remove this optional here
you will just get one solution yeah and
there's a construct query that says from
some pattern use a template to build
another graph so what you get back is
another graph so yeah and then there's a
asked query so you don't have to return
solutions you can just check that's a
certain graph pattern exists in a graph
and in this case it does there is a
fruit with color yellow next so what
we've seen so far rdf in memory
import/export and sparkle but there are
a lot of features that sparkle has so
let's continue with a break so do you
know wiki data yeah I assume that
everybody knew but recently I talked to
someone and didn't so I explained
quickly so maybe I've seen the info
boxes in Wikipedia right yeah so this is
the German info box and the same info
box in Hungarian for the German town
hood cut and it gives
different number for the population
density so that means someone should go
to the 300 different language versions
of that page and fixed it or now they
can go to Vicky's data and enter the
value there and then there are some info
boxes that now draw data from Mickey
data so Vicky's data is the it's made by
the same organization that makes
Wikipedia yeah what else does Vicky's
data give you so before when you wanted
to link to a concept you might have
linked to Wikipedia pages but then the
page name changes because there was a
dispute whether there is an accent over
the name or not and then you have to
update your data even Wikipedia itself
had this problem with the language links
yeah when one language link was stored
in the page changed it had to change in
300 other Wikipedia language versions of
that page yeah and now you use wiki data
to link your data so there's one
identifier this cue number here and it
will never change you can change the
label of that item but it won't affect
what you link to and from there you link
to the wikipedia pages if you like but
there's also other data not just links
to Vicki failure but arbitrary data like
numbers quantities images and so on so
how do you access that data you know
before that you had to parse these info
boxes from Wikipedia and that's what I
found for instance on the Slovak
Wikipedia maybe they were missing in -
here but it's not clear what that number
means yeah and now you can access the
same data without having to read a
Wikipedia page and there's an interface
for both humans and machines the one for
humans is here so you just enter a
sparkle query and get a result down here
but what I talked about now is this
machine interface so there's a sparkle
endpoint that I can query and the data
comes back and I show you how so that's
what we have Sparkle executes for it
encapsulates a lot
technology that we need so let's just
query now I do it life wiki data
I just asked wiki data the sparkle
endpoint count all the triples that you
have and I have three point seven
billion triples it's a lot of data I
couldn't put it on machine because I
don't have hundreds of gigabyte of RAM
so but we don't want to write some kind
of query string you know instead we want
to use the symbolic query and that's
possible too
so Sparkle execute takes here symbolic
variance or string whatever you like and
this one for instance finds all items
that are an instance of and potentially
subclass of a neurotransmitter and
optionally finds a formula and finds the
English label yeah and that's it so I
can quickly change that to German and
yeah I see the German label follow them
or any language that you like together
with the formula another example
taxonomy you start from a veil and
retrieve all the parent exons and
retrieve your build a graph from it yeah
it starts here the veil and it goes to
life or whatever now or some really
fancy query yeah you say Albert Einstein
had an employer who was of type
University and there was a start date
and end date associated with it and
there also a heli Halley's Comet passed
by a couple of times
earth yeah also has a date associated
visit and then you filter that and then
you figure out well that craft pardon
has one match yeah and that's when 1910
Halley passed and in between nineteen
nine and nineteen eleven Albert Einstein
was at the University of Chile so they
still have time oh no okay
you can use sparkle not only took very
sparkly end points but it's a nice
language so I just going to quickly show
how you can do queries against building
entities for instance you know so here
you can do basic things that you can do
with our current entity framework - yeah
like retrieving for each country the
population in the area and the results
is some Association now for each sub
graph that match the pattern you get the
bindings for the variables like the
United States as this population in this
area and I just limited to three now so
or reverse lookups find all movies
stirring but Spencer or mountains and
Italy higher than a certain height or
again movie so I've had Spencer but this
time also retrieved the image you know a
little bit more complicated an arbitrary
property chain that is actually tricky
to do currently you know so you start
with Germany go to the bordering
countries and then for the bordering
countries take the capital city and from
that the population and return all of
the data yeah
it's also spanning two domains country
and city now or aggregation find the
largest European countries by number of
ordering countries yeah so aggregation
we don't currently have an entity
framework so you would have to write
your own complicated code but sparkle
provides aggregation and it's doing the
entity queries for you here another
example but I continue a little bit more
here's something crazy so a simple
sounding very like finding by geographic
region the large longest river is
actually things it's actually quite
complicated so if you come up with more
simple query well let me know this one
uses the sub query and I found it
somewhere on the internet and translated
it to the symbolic Sparkleberry so
we saw a few more sings so I hope this
graph gets green soon
so from Sparkle inspired we have a few
new functions because everything
experimental nothing in any product yet
so graph cases let's start with some
graph that has some cycles and let's
find all cases of a graph that matches
that pattern yeah it starts from X goes
to Y from Y to C and from C back to X
and we don't want any duplicate cycles
there so we constrain X small Y small is
it yeah oh and then we want to see the
labels again and we see these two
matches from that you know so we have
some kind of sub graph matching or we
can just use a rule like in cases to
extract the data because I might not be
interested in the graph but in the
actual data or property pass yeah you
started one and at 200 find all the
paths and then returned the notes that
were visited no the edges that were
visited yeah so there's one that goes
along here and another path that goes
from one over 70/7 to 200 directly graph
matches sometimes you're just interested
in the bindings of the variables you
know we don't have a corresponding
Wolfram language function in general
pattern matching yet but this is an idea
and other functions like graph member Q
it's similar to the sparkle asked query
yeah that's a certain pattern have a
match sparkle update so there's a whole
language for updating graphs in sparkle
and here's an example so you start again
with a fruit graph and you insert some
more fruit you know or yeah this is for
explicit data or you have a more
complicated graph of geometric objects
and you made some kind of pattern and
from the solutions of that pattern you
populate a template that means all
objects that have a radius you want to
insert also the diameter which is two
times the radius yeah so now you have a
new graph that contains the diameter you
know which it didn't
for and there are various other
functions so let's do a interesting
thing so this is some kind of medical
research so if you had about drug
repurposing which medical drug can cure
a disease repurposing means that you
might be able to reuse it for another
disease yeah but you need suggestions of
how to do it and this paper tried to do
data analysis on a lot of public
datasets to find suggestions for we had
to do research and I converted this data
to RDF and I can start my local server
here I'm not going to do that now and
have a local sparkle endpoint running on
my machine I did that yesterday and it
has 2.3 million triples now and oh here
they find some prefixes I'll eat later
and then look up treatments yeah that
means find all compounds that tree to
come certain disease and return the
labels because we are humans we want to
see what actually yeah is so and we see
that compound treats that disease or
find the number of all treatments in
that database
yeah 750 and then find all the
combination of compound disease yeah
it's like two hundred thousand that
means there's a lot of potential for
combinations of treatment to disease
that might be investigated for
repurposing so let's look at path so I
want to find a path between this
arbitrarily chosen substance and this
disease to to see whether it has a path
that follows the properties up regulates
and interact with and associate so this
thing up regulates the gene and this
gene interacts with the other gene and
its associated with a certain disease
and we see a few solutions but there are
thousands paths of that particular type
so now let's count for all substance
disease pair how many paths are there of
that type and you see for instance for
this
more than 3000 parts of that particular
type
so now as your homework write a program
that generates all pass types and then
yeah count all the paths for all types
and then build a classifier that
predicts whether a certain compound
disease pair might be a treatment
chemical structure or don't have enough
time to explain that example it's about
looking no I want to explain it you can
also query custom custom entities using
sparkle so let's create some fancy
entity store it contains statements that
means constants the water boiling point
has three statements these statements
contain values and references and these
references have associated authors and
if you want to query such a complicated
structure using entities you are stuck
pretty soon yeah so for for instance the
walking speed of a dog you get back two
statements and from the statements you
have to look up the value and reference
yeah this Barkley you can do much more
complicated things for instance look up
all the values that have been reported
for the walking speed of a dog yeah or
all the values that are also referenced
using function sparkle exist you know
and then you can maybe read that on your
own but it's about finding in the data
authors that have reported suspicious
values and then queries at the end
excluding all of the values that have
been reported by suspicious Auto ESMA so
we have near covered nearly everything
and now let's come to the most
complicated topic trying to build an
entity store from an existing graph
database so Viki data has more than 3
billion triples and it's a lot of data
so I would like to build an entity store
that contains a view and a part of that
data and it's actually tricky to do that
because it's graph like data and
entities are some kind of rectangular
view so here's some experimental way to
specify what kind of data and what kind
of entities you want out of that huge
graph and what you do is for each type
that you want to define in this case I
want I'm interested in lakes and rivers
in Spain you define an entity filter
which can be arbitrarily complicated at
sparkle query but in this case it's just
something that says hey it's of type
Lake and it's in Spain yeah these are
all the entities for that type and then
you define properties the value of a
property might not be simple it might be
distributed over the graph like the unit
and the magnitude are different values
in the graph so you need a way to locate
these values associated with the correct
entities and later post-process these
things to turn it in the worm language
quantity object you know and let's just
see it how it works so it looks like
entities you can't distinguish them any
more so entity list works you see a list
of entities so there's 442 lakes just in
Spain known in Vicky's data you can look
up the lengths or an image yeah so the
image is retrieved so you retrieve from
the database a link to the image and
then it's imported yeah so you can do
entity class lookups like here give me
all the rivers that are longer than 900
kilometers yeah this is translated into
a sparkle query and it's done
efficiently on the Vicky's data service
so it means no no waiting on your site
or if
more complicated let's try to find all
the rivers in some geographic region
yeah also an entity class very and with
trans resort find all the lakes around a
certain point or retrieve a data set for
a single lake or a whole collection of
rivers and I think my time is up and we
went through Thanks